problem 41 use the histogram below to
answer the question that follows here's
our histogram two six-sided number cubes
they sound suspiciously like regular
dice two six-sided number cubes are
rolled simultaneously ten times it's
like you're rolling two dice ten times
the sums are recorded in the histogram
shown above so that when you look at
what's on top of your dice and you add
them up and then they recorded the
frequency of the different sums which of
the following statements can be inferred
from the histogram so the first one says
the mean is less than the median by 1/10
the mean okay so they're comparing the
mean in the median in every one of these
choices so we can actually look at this
histogram and figure out all of the
results that happened so the sum we got
three three times so we got three threes
three three three
we got one four we got three fives right
five had a frequency of three so five
five five and then we had no sixes and
then we had three sevens seven seven
seven so the median is easy to figure
out the median is literally just the
middle number so how many do we have
here one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so the middle number is
going to are the middle two numbers
because it's an even and if they're not
the same number we have to take the
average so what's the middle number if
we have four on this side and four on
this side the middle numbers right
because we have an even data set of five
so the median the median here is equal
to five now the mean is going to take a
little bit of more mathematics we're
going to have to sum up all of our
results and then divide by the total of
data points there are well actually I
should have known that there are 10 data
points we're going to divide by 10 so
what's the sum it's 3 times 3 so this is
9 plus 4 plus 5 times 3 or 5 times 3
here which is 15 plus 7 times 3 which is
21 so 9 plus 4 is 13 plus 50
mean plus 21 this is 13 plus 15 is 28
plus 21 28 plus 21 is 49 and if we have
to divide that by 10 we get an average
so if you divide it by 10 because we
have 10 data points the average is going
to be equal to 4 point 9 so our average
is 4 point 9 our median is 5 so our
average is 1/10 less than our median so
our or when I say average actually say
mean but it tends to mean you know when
people say average they tend to mean the
mean our mean when we just add up all
the data points 2/10 is 1/10 less than
the median so let's see the mean is less
than the median by 1/10 that looks right
our mean is less than the median by 1/10
choice a problem 42 use the graph below
to answer the question that follows
distribution of test scores all right
the graph above shows the distribution
of scores on a test with possible scores
of 10 20 30 40 50 and 60 those are the
only possible scores maybe there were
only 6 questions on the exam well yeah
sure
the minimum passing score was 40 so this
is the minimum passing score you have to
get at least a 40 to pass 20 girls and
20 boys took the test the percentage of
girls passing the test was how much
greater than the percentage of boys
passing the test all right so let's see
how many girls pass the test so this
dotted graph is the girls so 5 got a 40
so those pass they just barely passed so
you had those five girls get a 40 then
you had another 6 girls get a 50 so you
have another 6 girls get a 50 and then
you had another 4 girls get a 60 plus 4
so that's how many girls pass so that's
5 plus 6 is 11 plus 4 is 15 girls passed
girls passed there were a total of 20
girls so 15 out of 20 or you could think
of that as 70
five percent if you divide 15 by 20
that's the same thing as 3/4 or 75% of
girls passed now let's do the boys and
I'll do it in stereotypical colors the
boys in blue once again they have to get
abyss they have to get at least a 40 to
pass so six boys just barely passed got
the 40 then three boys got a fifty they
passed
plus two boys got a sixty they passed so
a total of 6 plus 3 plus 2 is 11 boys
past 11 out of 20 is the same thing as
what that's 55% if you multiply the
numerator the denominator by 5 you get
55 over 100 so this is equal to 55
percent of the boys passed now what did
they ask us I forgot already the
percentage of girls passing the test was
how much greater than the percentage of
boys passing the test so 75% is how much
greater than 55% well 75% minus 55
percent that's 20% the girl's percentage
is 20% larger than the boys percentage
is larger by 20% the percentage of girls
passing tests was how much greater than
the percentage of boys passing tests
right there was 20 percentage points
greater next question
43 use the table below to answer the
question of I think I've learned that a
marketing company conducted a survey to
determine milk shake flavor preferences
among five different age groups these
are the different age groups this is are
the different options I guess on
milkshakes based on the date of the
table what is the probability that a
randomly chosen 35 year old customer
will prefer a strawberry flavored milk
shake so a randomly chosen 35 year old
that puts us in this bucket right here
30 to 39 year olds so if they are just
if they can be described by the data
that we've collected already the
probability is the same ratio of the
data sample we've collected that
actually liked or is it straw
berry flavored milkshake so in that age
group how many total people did we
survey we surveyed we surveyed 8 plus 14
is 8 plus 14 is 22 22 plus 12 is 34 we
surveyed 34 people in this age group and
how many of them like two strawberry
milkshakes well 12 of them did 12 out of
34 12 out of 30 for 30 to 39 year-olds
liked strawberry milkshakes
so the probability if we use that as our
data that random 30 to 39 year old will
like strawberry milkshakes is 12 over 34
or if we put reduce this that's 6 over
17 just divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2 and that is d good
thing that that was one of the answer
choices D problem 44 problem 44 a child
has a set of blocks 4 of which are
square so we have 4 square 5 are round 5
are round and 6 are triangular 6 are
triangular the child randomly picks a
block from the set and gives it to his
sister the child then randomly picks one
more block so he didn't put that block
back in that's very important that the
first block what is the probability that
the first block was round the first
block was round and the second block was
triangular so the probability the first
block is round how many total blocks do
we have to start off with we have 15
right 4 plus 6 is 10 plus 5 is 15 so we
start off with 15 blocks and what is the
probability the first block is round
well five of them are round so there's a
5 over 15 probability so this is the
probability probability that first is
round right there and now what's the
probability that the second block is
triangular now remember we no longer
have 15 blocks in the pile now he's
taken one of the blocks and given it to
the sister so now we're choosing out of
14 blocks now and we're also and this is
an and so we're assuming so what is the
probability that the second block is
triangular
given that the first block was a circle
so we we assume that we still have our
full contingency of six triangles there
that that wasn't picked our first time
so the probability the probability the
second block triangular is there six
triangles there's six triangles out of
the 14 blocks left so our answer is
going to be 5 over 15 which is same
thing as 1/3 times 6 over 14 is the same
thing as 3 over 7 which is the same
thing as 1 over 7 and that is choice C
problem 45 use the spinner below to
answer the question that follows okay
there's our spinner the host of a party
tells her guests that every time the
spinner above lands on the section
labeled fruit basket that's the section
labeled fruit basket a guest will win a
large basket of fruit if 180 guests at
the party each spin the spinner once
what is the best estimate of the number
of fruit baskets that the host will be
given a wet giving away let's see we
have listed 1 2 3 4 5 they look about
equal you have five equal pies so it
looks like there's a point 2 or 20%
chance of getting fruit basket so each
person says can almost pretend like they
get point 2 of a fruit basket so they
have point to where maybe I say they
have a 1/5 chance and then you have a
hundred 80 of those people so times 180
I could have multiplied this times 180
this would be the expected value this
pected number root baskets I'm going to
give away so what's 1/5 times 180 or
well how many times does five goes in go
into 180 five goes into 18 three times
three times five is 15 G minus fifteen
is three thirty 36 times so I would
expect to give away 30 36 baskets